I didn't know I talked about it before I did it.
Um,
I hung up.
Or is this like online now?
Ah,
yeah.
Yeah.
Um,
dude,
your Internet legend right now.
It's online.
Oh yeah.
Um,
oh cool.
Wait,
this is on.
Do you see that old couple who couldn't figure out the Webcam?
No.
Was a funny like viral video of this old couple trying to figure out how to work
their Webcam and the webcams.
Ron,
it's recording the whole time.
Oh Wow.
Yeah,
it's like cute.
Um,
did you imagine being an old person dealing with the Internet and now they must
feel ripped off?
I already find little things that I'm already getting annoyed about.
Like I'm doing the thing where I don't want to learn it be type thing.
You know?
Like how like my dad doesn't want a iPhone.
He wants a phone and he doesn't want anything else.
He doesn't want to worry.
You know what I mean?
Crazy people.
Right.
Those crazy people.
Hey,
I don't look it.
I don't want no taxes.
Yeah.
I used to be like,
I want a camera on you.
And you're like,
heck for anything though.
Or I mean,
I find myself things like,
like maybe video games maybe or something like that.
The,
the swarm of technology overwhelmed my life so quickly.
I embraced it so quickly.
I used to joke about text messages.
I had a bit about it.
Well,
why is it good
miss?
It's been a long time since I left the fucking phone on ladies and gentlemen and
I do apologize.
Maybe it's a color.
It's a late night podcast folks and I had been done.
Don't fear factor all day.
I know you're tired.
I don't know what's going on.
Let's hope they don't call back.
Fucks are.
I like to hear who it is.
It's kind of,
this one doesn't tell you a better phone though.
I gave up on it.
Just constantly telling me who's calling.
Sometimes I don't give a fuck.
I don't want to be that voice to that electronic voice.
It fucks up everybody's name.
Well,
receiving call from Brendan Dunn bubble shows it repeated over and over.
Or do you have any audit answering machines laying around?
No.
You should read if you,
if you have one,
find it like if you have one in your basement or your garage,
plug that shit in and just listen to the messages of your life from what,
seven years ago or something like that.
And it was the most creepiest shit ever.
I was like,
wow,
I was in a weird place right there,
you know,
like,
Hey Brian,
I need you to work to double shifts here and there.
And uh,
I think I've got my girlfriend pregnant.
We're going to go over and do the bowling alley later and I'm just like,
what
you used to talk to when you were in Ohio?
Yeah.
Like people from Ohio and stuff like that.
It was so fucking weird.
Do you look back on people from Ohio?
Like they don't know that Ohio is like escape
I think.
I think people don't know how I would just feel trapped.
Like,
it's more like they don't trap they I think,
I don't think,
yeah,
I felt trapped when I was there,
you know,
because you don't make a lot of money when you live in Ohio for the majority of
people,
you know,
or at least a class I was in,
I would,
I was just working like job to job,
getting laid
off,
you know,
whatever cause do another job.
And it was just like,
wow,
$13 an hour,
Ooh,
$14 an hour or something like that.
And uh,
but I didn't have enough money to like move or go to California that seemed like
out of like s ridiculous,
you know,
it's,
it's a,
it's hard to move from like everywhere.
Especially with family.
Like the neighborhood I grew up in,
is it the same way?
Like when I moved to,
I lived in Ireland for a year in like 96 and it blew people's mind.
They were like,
how the fuck do you go to Ireland?
Like,
what do you just bought a plane ticket?
And I was like,
yeah,
you can do that.
So that's what you did.
You didn't know anybody in Ireland.
You just,
yeah,
I just went.
That's pretty savage.
I love that.
I love that idea.
That's awesome.
That must've been a hell of an experience.
It was fun.
Yeah.
You learn a lot.
You learned that things usually work out.
What was the motivation for that?
Uh,
I actually,
you know,
I did talk about this on Marin's podcasts recently.
Just play Marin's podcasts.
We'll go back and take it was,
I mean,
the short story is I was a,
somebody I knew drowned and I knew and I had to identify their body.
Whoa.
And,
and it just kind of like,
I was like 23 and she was pretty young.
She was like 22 or 23 and I was like,
and she was going taking classes in the summer to graduate college earlier.
And I just thought like,
oh,
she's taking classes,
like doing all this shit.
She didn't want to do,
I don't know.
I just was like,
oh,
you can just do whatever you want.
Like,
and life's short I guess,
or I don't know.
But I just,
that was kind of the motivation for fucked.
And I saw a cheap ticket yeah.
To,
to Ireland.
I think you might've told him the story before,
but it's a fascinating nonetheless.
But we very rarely get to see dead bodies.
You know,
we,
it's so rare that you get to see one.
I remember when I saw my grandfather,
my grandfather died of cancer and when,
uh,
when I went to the morgue,
you know,
when they have all dressed up and shit.
Yeah.
And you still standing near the body.
I was like in the Cask,
I realized,
I was like,
this is the first dead body I've ever been around.
I've never really been around a dead body.
It's amazing that all these people die,
but we do such a good job of keeping bodies away from,
from people's funerals.
Yeah.
Because it's so disturbing.
Well,
like viewing,
so it doesn't,
doesn't never kind of tweak you out when you think about a dude who be a
mortician.
I mean,
I understand that it's a very important job.
I understand it's an important job.
I do get it.
And,
and,
you know,
forensic medicine and the idea of,
solving crimes and,
you know,
checking people's corpses and shit like that.
Dr. Michael and I love that it's,
that's an amazing show that HBO show,
but doesn't it fucking freak you out that they're handling dead bodies?
There's something about that man that tweaks my hand.
Yeah,
just touch and dead bodies.
The IMD a just the possibility,
and I know this is not the case with these doctors and I know it's most likely
not the case with 99.9% of the morticians,
but the fact that
there's like the 1% that it would enjoy fucking moving them around and smacking
him and putting on little shows from south that,
um,
Sam Kennison bit.
I fucking made me pee my pants at first time I heard it.
That kid bit got me when he lays him about doing standup comedy that bit,
and it wasn't even told by Sam Kennison.
It was told by a girl that I worked with,
ah,
I was working at this health club and this girl came in and she was just fucking
laughing.
She's like,
oh my God,
if that it heavy Boston accent.
I saw a fucking this guy on TV,
Sam Kinison all my God,
he was so fucking funny.
Sue.
She goes and she did on the floor.
She got down on the stomach.
He didn't live,
keeps fucking,
she did it and she did a pretty good job of it because I was laughing so hard.
I was like,
wow.
He said what?
Like that's the craziest thing I've ever heard of.
And then I got ahold of the VHS tape and I remember watching that bid going,
God damn like that's comedy too.
That's comedy too.
I thought comedy was that evening at the Improv stuff.
I thought comedy for white guys was,
you roll up your sleeves and you'd talked about pet food.
You know what I mean?
That's really what you saw on TV a lot.
And as a child I saw that.
And you know,
occasionally you saw something on the tonight show like
delirious.
I don't know.
I'm a little younger than you.
When I was 14 I saw delirious and Andrew dice clay.
That is special from the Tla.
Yeah,
that was,
yeah,
delirious is another one.
I didn't then raw or delirious might have been so good that I never even thought
I could possibly do stand up at that time.
Really ridiculous.
I think it was,
I was getting older when Kennison came around,
I was more confident to keep,
I think delirious was when I was younger and I remember watching them,
my friend Jimmy lawless,
his house,
me and him and his sister were watching this and it fucking,
it was so funny.
No,
it's not Jimmy John Battle Raco sister for the record.
We're all sitting around and we're watching it.
And it was so fucking funny that we were like embarrassed to be sitting next to
each other.
I don't know.
It was so good for the time,
you know,
over a teenagers and high school.
Eddie Murphy raw was just like,
or delirious rather.
It was just really good.
I rented raw recently again and it's it,
did you like it?
I did,
cause I wasn't super,
I saw it a couple times when I was a kid and,
uh,
just rented it because I couldn't really remember any bits from it.
And uh,
and it,
it's pretty good.
I mean,
I don't know.
It's something this down just to it too,
right.
Algia to it,
but it's like,
God,
he's wearing like this leather suit that's awesome.
Filing suit.
It was awesome.
Yeah.
Martin Lawrence had some fucking awesome suits too.
Black guys can pull that off.
You know?
Could you imagine if some white comic went onstage?
You know,
Patton Oswald started off doing all of his shit and a leather suit.
Yeah.
You know,
that'd be hilarious.
It's something weird about that,
man.
Black comics can go way more sexy.
They can go way harder.
Yeah.
No,
that's true.
It's funny when my friend died.
Do you know Chelsea Peretti?
Chelsea Peretti.
I know the names.
She's fine.
She did a half hour for special for comedy central last year and uh,
she was going to wear the red leather suit that Eddie Murphy wars delirious.
We're trying to find something.
I don't know if she really was going to do it.
But did you watch the roast of Charlie Sheen when Mike Tyson,
uh,
held out his fist and Steve overpass facing him broke his nose.
That was,
that was funny.
But you know what,
what,
what was the funniest part was that woman who was that?
Oh,
the one that just attacked the one that went after s?
Yeah.
Who is that?
Amy Schumer.
Yeah,
that's what it is,
dude.
She's hilarious.
She's really funny.
Oh my God.
She attacked Mike Tyson.
It was one of the most bold and vicious insult attacks I've ever seen.
And Tyson tried to come back,
like tried to go after.
He said something like,
um,
I think if there was as many digs out you that within you,
you will look like a porcupine.
Something like that.
Yeah,
that's exactly what it,
is that what he said?
Yeah.
And she just goes,
does anyone have a translator for that?
Yeah.
She was really fun.
God,
I thought it was good though.
The whole show.
I didn't it,
I didn't watch it,
but I heard her shit.
They were planning on Opie and Anthony.
I was fucking howling when she said about Bruce Willis and I'm Charlie Sheen
being really similar because they were both big in the eighties and now they're
having their old slots filled by Ashton Kutcher
far less good.
That's fucking hilarious.
Yeah,
that's a great joke.
It's a really well worded too.
She's hilarious.
Oh my God,
that girl's funny.
Seth Macfarlane was an awesome,
it was awesome on that too.
I have to watch it.
I'll have to watch it,
but
honestly,
I don't enjoy roasts for the most part.
I usually find them to be mean spirited and fucking weird.
I don't,
I've never wanted to do them.
I didn't want to fucking shit on someone that hard right in front of them.
I just,
it's like I don't,
it's cute and everything.
I mean,
it's fun to watch,
but no thanks man.
If everybody knows each other really well too,
you know,
like if you're all friends,
busting each other's balls,
but sometimes it's not,
don't matter the gender.
Watch the ones where they went after Pam Anderson.
I didn't,
I don't think I saw the panel Anderson won,
but I haven't seen the Joan Rivers one either.
Ruthless,
ruthless.
It's ruthless shit like you sit and watch it.
I don't remember any specific,
I very possibly,
I don't remember specifics,
but I remember being like listening to it gone,
oh,
I don't want to hear this.
Like,
what are you doing?
You are you voicing what the problem is.
It's funny.
That's the problem.
The problem is it's good stuff.
You know?
I mean,
you're insulting the fuck out of someone hurting their feelings for no reason.
But to me it's kind of hilarious and it's unfortunate that it is,
you know?
But when you're hearing her tee off on Mike Tyson was talking about Mike Tyson
having,
uh,
a slut,
a tattoo on his face.
You know that my Ben don't know whether to punch him or to finish on him.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Really.
I fucked it up.
I think too.
I fucked up.
But it's great stuff.
But it's so mean.
You're like,
whoa.
Any Jessel nick had a couple really good ones.
Good again towards Mike Tyson.
He said,
I'm paraphrasing,
but the joke basically was,
um,
best way to describe Mike Tyson is the same name of a Richard Pryor album,
meaning not nigger's crazy was awkward and then nobody really got it.
I got it.
And it was and Patrice O'Neal or what guy?
And Nick.
He's a white guy.
Um,
but he,
he didn't cut guy but he,
yeah,
but he didn't say the name of the album.
Oh no,
he didn't.
Oh.
Oh,
I've said as in,
and that was the joke that he was going to spell it out to everybody.
No,
he didn't spell it out.
He just left it at the same cause I was like,
wow.
No the same way or whatever.
Yeah,
he is the best way to describe him as the name of a Richard Pryor album and,
and Patrice O'Neil.
It doesn't go over very well on that tree.
Says,
uh,
he goes,
oh,
there's too many,
uh,
too many white people here,
man.
They're not going to get that.
And Jasmine,
it goes,
have you ever heard anybody say there are too few black people here?
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Yeah.
Those roofs,
those roles can get mean man.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I haven't seen a ton of them.
I heard the Joan Rivers one is good.
I heard when she comes back it's really funny.
Yeah.
[inaudible] back at them.
Wow.
She's great.
That documentary.
It was pretty good.
Did you see that?
I have not seen it,
but a lot of people recommended it.
What is it called again?
The Joan Rivers documentary.
I mean if you Google that,
it'll come up.
Um,
I think,
what the fuck is it called?
Gooseneck.
Is that what it is?
No.
Do you think she writes all her jokes?
Did he think she has like,
she buys jokes.
She doesn't people,
but she probably rights.
I mean she's pretty quick on the civil work.
A piece of work.
That's really good.
I knew it was some kind of euphemism on facelifts.
Yeah,
it kind of is
a lot of people.
Totally worth,
did you see her on Louie?
No,
I didn't.
Do you watch,
do you guys watch Louis?
I didn't see her and Louis though.
I was a funny one too.
That's,
she's really funny.
It's a funny episode.
Season finale or something?
No,
it was early in the season.
I got to get into Louie.
I cut way back on my TV watching.
I cut way back to the point where I'm only watching like documentaries.
Shit.
Yeah.
I just stopped.
I mean,
occasionally I'll watch like a ancient aliens.
Yeah,
I love that show,
man.
I love the idea of Vr.
That breaking bad Louie breaking bad is awesome.
Breaking bad's at best,
you know?
But Patton Oswald said it best.
He said,
I feel like it's homework.
You know when you get into a show,
it's like,
it's homework.
It's like you've got to keep up with these fucking DVR.
Oh Man.
That's it.
That's what like it's a godsend.
You just fucking watch it.
About about like mad
men.
Everybody keeps telling me to mad men.
It's amazing.
I'm like,
no,
we missed it so crazy.
Unless,
unless we get a wicked flu,
but you where he can tear through the four seasons in a weekend.
I mean,
we're four seasons behind us.
48 hours of television.
I missed last though.
I can't stop.
I wish I could talk about loss and theories.
I'm missing go fuck itself.
I Know Jack killed it for me.
Who send it in by the end of the show there's like,
oh,
I guess they brought him back to life.
He was like completely phoning in it and towards the end of the show Jack,
he killed it for me.
That was the doctor.
Doctor.
Doctor killed it for me.
I had to stop watching.
I had stopped watching.
I'm like,
this guy is not really there.
He is not in the moment here.
Okay.
I'm not believing that you just dumped a body in this fountain and then brought
in front of you.
You barely paid attention deuce.
Right.
You know,
I kind of fell off with I,
I kind of fell off with loss pretty quickly.
It was fun for awhile,
but it can't fuck with Battlestar Galactica.
Battlestar Galactica was one of the best unexpected fun shows to follow.
That's a good God damn show.
That was a really good fucking show.
If you want to like sit down.
I think they went a few seasons.
How many seasons did they go for?
Five or something like that.
Either way.
It's a bad ass fucking show.
That's a good show.
I watched the whole thing on DVD almost after the fact.
Then caught up right at the very last season.
You just have to be in the mood.
It's like when you tear through a book or something,
like sometimes I'll have like three books that I want to read and they just sit
there and I'm like,
ah,
I don't want to touch them yet.
But then when you do make a commitment and you just fly through it,
a lot of people probably angry at me for what I said about lost.
I used to love the sharp people don't get,
don't get me running and she gave,
I used to love the show.
I'd love to show,
but it did bug me for real.
It did bug me.
I kind of explained a lot of that.
Okay,
I believe you.
But you know what?
I love the fact that I never watched the ending.
You don't see it like that because it means you didn't get me.
You don't even need,
ain't going.
No,
he didn't get me.
Bitch.
I snuck away clean.
I no longer feel your pole.
Yeah,
I no longer feel your poll.
I'm afraid you're a dealer.
They're all dealers,
bro.
All these people with TV shows,
me included.
I'm guilty as well.
We're all dealers.
Get you hooked on some fucking crazy shit.
I love being hook chain breaking bad man.
That's a great fucking show.
Ooh,
I don't want to be spoiler alert,
spoiler alert.
But when he had the dude locked up in the basement and he had that moral
decision to make,
did you watch that?
You know he's had,
he's had some altercations with gang bangers and stuff.
Yeah,
there's a meth dealer.
And do you remember the one we had the guy locked up in the basement.
He had to figure out whether you should kill him or not.
Kept this season.
That's how it was last season.
Oh,
last year.
I think it was last season.
Yeah.
Either way.
It was like one of the most intense scenes like I think I've ever seen in a,
in a,
like a made for television show.
It was like a movie.
It was a movie scene.
So fucking intense,
man.
Yeah.
That guy can act as fucking ass off.
They're great.
Everybody is great on that one.
What is the lead guy's name?
Bryan Cranston.
And I've really like a Gus man.
That guy.
Really?
I don't know how up on it you are,
but the last few episodes,
Gus is really,
which one's the head?
The like the,
the guy who owns the chicken shops,
the head,
the black dude with the glasses don't drug dealer.
Oh God.
The guy that,
that um,
Walter and Jesse workforce in the bay time lever for fucking television.
I mean it must be right if you stop and think about some of the show,
I mean mad men,
people are really into,
which I'm sure is good.
Three me people were obsessed with mad men.
People were obsessed with you.
Even if you watch anything on NBC,
like any of the new shows,
they fucking all suck.
Like they scare me.
How bad is,
they have laugh tracks again.
They,
they,
it's,
it's like there's a show laugh tracks are awesome with Christiana.
I think if you use laugh tracks and you should have to not be good at it,
you should have to do it,
but you,
you,
you can't,
you can't like let it fade off here if you're going to use the last track.
Yeah,
really obvious and fake people would probably start losing their minds.
Like what would be like driving people crazy idea,
man.
The idea of a laugh track where we're going to tell you that it's funny.
We're going to end,
we're not even going to do it in front of a live audience.
We're going to insert some fucking,
this is where we want you to laugh.
Stupid.
[inaudible] I think Tim Heidecker tweeted or he's got somebody removed the laugh
track from an episode of Big Bang theory I think or how I met your mother or
something and I didn't hear,
him and Dunkin were talking about it the other night and uh,
I haven't seen it.
Well in all fairness,
what it sounded a little areas,
a lot of those takes,
could have very easily have been a second and third takes of a scene that you do
in front of a live audience.
And they just don't get a laugh.
I think he had somebody go in and just remove it.
Well it could be,
but I'm saying,
you know,
sometimes you have to do a scene,
if you're doing like a live sitcom in front of an audience,
like on news radio we would fuck up or you know,
we would have to do something over again cause they wanted to rewrite something.
And so we would do the same scene several times.
So it could very easily have been that even if you don't hear the audience
laughing,
it could have been that we would the film stuff after the fact,
like there was be scenes,
it wouldn't work pickups.
So yeah.
And we would,
we would like make totally new lines and the producers would like fake laugh on
the side.
They will like stand there and [inaudible] and all of jokes,
Huh?
It was,
it was so alien mouse.
So bizarre.
I'm surprised you weren't offered for two and a half men.
Where are you?
Well,
no way,
man.
I think you'd be up for that.
I'm not famous enough for that.
How long were you on news radio?
Um,
five years.
I think it would be awesome.
Different.
That's a different level of fame they're looking for.
They're looking for that Ashton Kutcher fame.
That's several.
Ashton Kutcher not be the guy from jackass.
Why is it,
it's so ridiculous this cause the other ones on Twitter or,
or uh,
uh,
whatever nature pumps.
It's like,
it's like,
I think his Twitter followers has gotten into everybody's heads that he's not
the guy on the camera commercials,
you know?
Well,
the kid is a fucking business genius.
He's got a lot of shit going on,
man.
He's very smart and very,
I'm not saying he's not,
I'm just saying I'm going to say next.
So ridiculous.
How like,
it's like he's looked upon like a Brad Pitt or something.
Well,
he's the handsome guy,
man.
He's a gorgeous dude.
He's like six foot perfect bone structure.
Yeah.
Well,
no,
for real.
I mean he girls love that guy.
There's a reason why they love him.
He's delicious.
Yeah,
I mean pretty well liked across the,
yeah,
he's now I get no,
I met him,
get it from,
I worked for them actually.
Um,
there was,
um,
I did a game show in my head this,
a show that was his production company produced.
I mean,
I only got to meet him once very briefly,
but it was a nice car.
He's just,
he seems like he's got his game together.
It was let them do this crazy show game show in my head.
It was pretty good in this show though.
I'm not saying I never watched two and a half men in the first place,
but did you watch the new one?
The new episode with him?
It was very dark,
very like,
whoa.
They,
they,
they uh,
took a weird approach where they're making fun of his day.
I kind of want to see it,
watched it before,
but I want to watch it because of the controversy.
You know,
I want to watch,
I watched one episode once and I thought it was kind of lame.
No,
I didn't think it was kind of lame.
I thought it was terrible.
I don't remember what was going on,
but I remember like,
like what is this?
This is,
you know,
when you see something it's just like alien.
It's like,
it's so not funny that it just te Torques your insides.
Like what?
And it was like that and so I never watched it again.
But that happens on any sitcoms.
There's a lot of weird sitcoms up there.
I left.
I like,
I,
I uh,
I watched a couple recently and uh,
yeah,
they just,
they were baffling.
I don't want to say their names.
I don't know.
She's hard to do.
It's hard to do a sitcom right now.
Most of them really,
a lot of people get involved in the mix,
you know?
It's only when someone has like awesome control over things.
Like when one person is artistic vision can truly shine through like the south
park situation.
Those guys are so awesome that no one fucks with them.
So they just do their shit,
which is why their show so fucking brilliant.
It's like there's no more clear APP like point like of a of reference.
If you'd like thinking about like one prime example of a show where you can tell
the artistic minds behind it.
Don't have any influence by anybody else.
It's how far right.
Yeah,
it's cause it's such a money jungle.
He,
yeah,
yeah.
I would say he's right there.
Yeah.
I wish Louie was longer.
I wish they would pay him five times more and just have hour and a half does
everything himself.
Yeah,
but when you watch that show,
it's so
short.
Like you really start getting into it and then it just drops out.
It's cause it's like 22 minutes long.
Well
do you think about doing everything yourself and doing it on a laptop?
That's what he does.
He does it all.
He edits it on a fucking 13 inch Mac book pro.
Unless he's like trolling.
Yeah,
he's trying to play the like fucking super hard worker do it.
But really it's got like a whole crew credited you Mexicans with fucking stolen
laptops.
It changes.
It goes from like edited by Louis Cane and sometimes it's not edited by the way.
Oh really?
So He has other people working with him
good that he can trust people enough with his baby like that.
But because I,
you know,
I talked to him after he did his first show at Louis C CK.
Everybody knows if you don't know,
stand up wise is one of the best comics alive.
He's like the elite of the elite.
He's just a great comic,
you know.
But his,
his HBO show,
just what didn't click,
you know,
some people liked it.
Lucky Louie.
Some people liked it.
It just,
there was something off about it.
There was something,
there was two,
two ham handed and I talked to him about it and I said,
if he,
if he could do it all over again,
what would you do differently?
He was like,
I would,
I would fire everybody.
He goes on fire,
all the writers and he goes,
I'm saying,
I'm sorry.
You know you're,
you're my friend.
I love you,
but I need someone else to do this.
I got one shot at this.
I got one shot at this to do this.
Right.
Wow.
And so you know,
when he did,
he did.
He fired everybody.
Now he's doing it.
All of it himself,
you know?
That's amazing.
It's so weird how he showed doesn't fall any kind of guideline like,
like one day his daughter is somebody else.
Girlfriend's
daughters are pretty consistent.
I know her kids,
not all the time.
It changes.
There was like a totally different girl there the other day and I'm like,
who's this girl?
Are you sure?
Yeah.
Are you sure about that man?
Almost.
I'd probably say 99% sure.
I would think to doubt about that.
I was Louie,
if I could deal with the daughter,
I would think that he would work out a deal with the daughter because they have
a handful of episodes that revolve around the daughters.
I think I have to make sure that that would take me out of the show a little
bit.
It's daughters kept changing.
That would fuck with my head.
I'll have to take,
it kind of freaks me out.
That's,
I mean,
I'm a huge fan of that show,
so I'm pretty sure unless I was just dreaming the whole thing once rogue and was
kissing some guy,
hey,
fellow Google it.
Don't,
don't keep bringing me into your fucked up world,
dude.
I want out
the guy.
The other guy was delicious.
We need to take less of those,
those Alpha brands,
son.
Oh yeah.
I'm excited about taking those.
I'll give you something so they're back in stock,
right?
Everything's good to go.
Yeah.
It's not going to talk.
Did you see a website by the way?
On the banner?
Yeah.
There's a banner on my website.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on it,
I looked at them during the code name Rogan.
You can get 10% off of your Alpha brain.
It's juicy.
It's becoming an Alpha brand commercial.
I think we better stop for kids
right now.
I'm excited about it.
You're going to find out.
It's interesting stuff,
but you know,
people know this case
vitamins for your dome son.
There's a thing on the page.
Two of these are like a
medical editor wrote some editorial of references as to why this stuff works.
Is His name Joey Coco Diaz.
Doctor Joey wasn't cock socket.
Made this shit myself.
My special blend.
So I was over listening to a gay guy the other day at the comedy store.
We're over listening to a gay guy.
I was paying too much attention and uh,
he was going off on one of these like how everybody's gay.
Like we were looking at the billboard,
which was that guy from CNN that just moved to like Fox with Anderson Cooper.
And he was like,
just like,
I can't believe he hasn't come out yet.
He's Super Gay.
I know a lot of people that said,
he's like,
oh,
I see.
I had no idea.
I don't even fucking,
and you're trying to out him,
look at you.
And then,
and then he was saying how that nobody,
here's the words that he was saying how the new president of a apple is gay and
I didn't know that.
So now I'm just wondering if it's,
so now max really will be gay.
Yeah.
We're going back to shiny white Arizona
because people are always like back Sergei
online man,
you're old.
Yeah.
Well those are the best kissers online.
The message boards and shit and Max are always treated as pretentious slobs who
can't work real computers like the vast majority are really,
it seems like there's a camp,
there's a PC camp and there's a Mac camp.
And one of the things that people always say is Max or gay,
but now max really are gay dude.
Yeah.
I wonder what gay things are going to happen to our Max.
They're the best.
You're embarrassed.
So I have,
I have a PC and I'm,
cause I feel like people with Max just really looked down their nose at people,
a pcs.
And I know it's not cool to have one,
but you know what man,
I don't,
I don't fucking edit.
Yeah.
Music or videos.
Really hair CESC objectives.
Brand new fucking kick ass easy.
Like you weren't keeping buck if you were given a Mac.
Yeah,
you would use that Mac and then never go back the same way.
If like if you get an iPhone,
you might be the biggest talks.
You shouldn't shit talker ever saying droids the best and everything.
Every person I know that you used to be that person got an iPad.
You're just like all those crazy wind.
I'm just going to,
you're just like all those crazy windows people.
I'm going to get attacked like I don't care that much about stuff.
It's crazy that we didn't even think about it.
It's so weird thing that people are have amazing desire to be on teams.
Yeah,
sorry.
that's crazy.
You can eat a dick.
That's what I'm saying.
Hey listen.
The house pitches and the startup times quicker than ever.
I was watching something on,
on the online where they're showing how quick the startup time is a windows
eight and from the time you press the button,
eight seconds and windows eight starts up and it's like really quick.
It's like Doo,
Doo,
Doo Doo.
So what,
when it runs it sucks theater but we know who's freaking out about how long it
takes her computer to start,
isn't it on most of the time,
99.9% of what the fuck are you even my
computer's a piece of shit and uh,
it starts up fast enough for like,
do you give viruses?
No,
never.
You don't go to the dirty,
dirty,
dirty sites and then all sudden every time you tried to grab the whole browser a
fucking pop up pops up.
No,
no.
It happened with my girls laptop.
She had this thing called malware or something like that.
And you all were aware.
I don't even know what it is because I've been on,
I don't know.
I've heard about where male where all your ticket about is this gay shit.
All Qa.
It was so bad that that that Norton didn't do kid and do anything.
None of the chances aren't doing.
Jim Norton can do anything about it.
It's like,
and it got so bad that like there was nothing you could do is I started to do
registry edits and like fucking tried to add,
do safe mode things just to get this thing off.
It was like sending information.
It was a reading passwords.
It was,
it tricked itself as a,
uh,
windows of virus protection.
So on top of it it was like saying,
here's the way to get this off your computer.
Click here to buy this virus scanning software.
And so then now you're giving your credit card information and sending your shit
just to get some fucking thing to unlock on your computer to get your computer
back.
So I had to fucking company,
like I even,
I followed all these instructors.
I finally pretty much just had to wipe the whole thing and it was so common.
I found out like this is a normal thing that a lot of people get.
This is not like some crazy virus she got out of nowhere.
Holy Shit.
What is it called?
Uh,
something antivirus.
I read something insane like the number of,
uh,
what are the number of computer viruses out there?
What would you say it is?
Oh,
there's a ton of them.
I don't know.
It's 480,000 I would say.
I'd probably say it's in the millions.
Millions.
I'm trying to find it because it's so ridiculous.
Okay.
But Apple's sucking a Dick Lately,
so I might be going back to PC.
I just got that final cut pro and I had to pretty much read,
learn everything.
And I feel dumb because it's so s one
that's just one program though.
Well that's,
that's one of their main programs.
They pretty much decided to take their main
mad at all of apple because of one thing.
Oh No.
Well I mean if that's the direction they're going where they're like making
everything more,
I don't know,
like friendly or ha look easy looking or you know,
simple cut and paste,
you know.
And that like,
I mean,
the old final cut pro is like you had pretty much,
you could do anything you want.
Uh,
this is like you're,
you're,
you have to do like backwards steps and do all this extra bullshit just cause it
looks pretty.
Yeah.
Well listen,
how crazy this answer as to how many computer viruses,
it's not exactly known,
but most likely in the millions.
The real problem is that new ones pop up every day.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I guess millions.
Millions meant well from,
Oh that are out there right now.
Or from the stealing your personal information that exist.
Yeah.
I don't know ma'am.
Possible.
How can going,
somebody might just be talking shit,
I need to get verification.
Milligan's you've got to think how many people does it take to make one computer
virus?
Why is it just one dude alone just gets crazy and makes us on his own?
Or is there other people involved?
Like how many people are making these things?
I think what it is though,
there's a lot of these viruses are just all variation.
So like you'll have one virus that somebody will change something small in it,
like the ports or whatever and it's called something else.
You know,
I don't think it's like all new voters.
People get out of it just like mischief fucking with people.
Apparently there's the ones that go,
that's all their goals is to steal your information or you're trying to get your
credit card information.
A lot of people have all that stuff stored on their,
uh,
on their computers.
You know,
they have,
uh,
you know,
you have the,
the,
the ie wallet set up so that you have all your credit card information.
So if you want to buy something,
you can just use that.
Oh yeah.
I don't get to do that.
I just memorize.
I know my credit card number is a Google wallet.
Is that a new thing?
I think they've had it for a while,
but I never used it for real or right.
Mind is going to use Google wallet.
What an amazing name.
Give them my phone.
They keep trying to get for my g mail,
a phone number for that.
And I'm like,
what the fuck do you need my phone number for it?
Fuck you dude.
Yeah.
You know,
email,
you could recover it in case someone steals your passwords password.
I'm an idiot.
We just need you to know real good.
You already have a secondary
fucked up when
you ran out of Gmail space yet.
No,
I have not.
I at 96% that's why stop sending pictures of your Dick all around town.
But what happens is Christ kid,
why can't I do that all around town?
His Dick,
his caucus,
like Banksy frank.
See it's all around.
Did I tell you how I have a fake picture of my Dick that a fake one that looks
exactly like my bedroom window said lately.
I say this,
I have been sending it out to random people like,
hey,
why don't you come over and I'll just send it and it looks like it would be me
laying in my bedroom and I'll send it to like a sentence,
a little Esther.
And she was like,
oh my God,
what the fuck,
lol.
And she goes,
Ooh.
And then I send it to somebody else and goes,
all right,
that was uncalled for.
And Yeah.
Do people don't want you sending the cards here today?
It's not my dig it.
It looks like my bedroom and it looks like it would could be my dick.
The Dick has like this weird black helmet on it and it looks like ridiculous.
If you really think that's my Dick,
but all these,
is it really though?
It's just a picture I found on Google.
Oh,
why are you sending people pictures?
So it's a real day when you do this,
you just put your head on the body or no,
it just looks like somebody laying what looks exactly like my better.
Okay,
I get it,
but there's a real,
there's an actual dictator.
Then it's fucking his dick.
This is a big cover story.
Why?
It's so lame.
He's planned this out.
He's got to get through it.
He's got to get to this cover story.
It's funny you got the same grape juice staying alive.
It's fucking bedroom pods.
Look at his cock.
It's a trick.
I'm going to send it to you.
I'll send it to you.
Tell me how you would react if you saw this or then you look at it and he made
you look at his dick.
It's a trick.
It's trickery.
So how could you be shocked at all?
Did anybody freak out that you just send them pictures?
Because I would send it to like ex girlfriends and ex girlfriends.
They don't want that shit in their life.
No Way.
Plus Dick and recognize your dick or I'll send it to other common looks,
deformed
black helmet.
Like if you hadn't Bangor and six,
eight months say and she started dating someone else.
Do you think she would remember?
You're like,
what?
It looked like?
Identify your Dick Shelly.
Oh,
put Dick puts on gas.
Was it?
Does it have a boner?
Is it flashed age?
It's just pretty quick head and like thick.
It's a big thick,
juicy dick.
Let's call a three quarter hard on from now on the Brett Farve,
let's call it,
cause he retired or is he playing again?
He's gonna play with Michael Vick,
right?
Isn't that the story of what he's going to go on the eagles?
I think that's what I'd heard.
I know nothing about football though.
I might have heard that from Joey Diaz.
They've got to get that cock suck on and he's going to show him how to play
fucking football.
I was going to make them billions,
dog millions,
so new Orleans was awesome.
New Orleans,
you should have to have a passport to go to that fucking place,
man.
That's another country.
New Orleans is another country that's a wild ass place.
I have never been in a city that has such a unique personality as New Orleans.
It's like the whole city.
It's small and it's cranked up to nine like everything's cranked up and people
are friendly.
It's fuck everyone's drunk as shit.
It's like,
I feel fucked up if you're not drunk.
You know,
Dunkin and I were doing shots with dinner.
We never have shots with dinner.
Dinner,
we got down.
I said,
I feel like having some fucking whiskey goes,
it's New Orleans,
man.
It tells it to you.
We're fucking doing shots while we eat and crab cakes.
We went out and we had a show at the house of Blues.
It was fucking awesome.
It was the energy in the room was just,
whew.
It was fun.
What's the hot chick level for new islands?
They're beautiful.
A lot of beautiful girls.
We,
there was a burlesque show on after us.
We stayed in watch a burlesque show,
which is very strange.
Like everybody like dresses up.
Like they're from a different time period.
Yeah.
And they kind of like dance around and some of it did.
The,
although beautiful is quite aimless.
It's like it's just a lot of dancing around and you're like,
I guess you're just celebrating how she was dressed and dancing around.
It was kind of fun because everybody was drunk and getting into it.
But it's so many drunks and so many fucking happy people.
Like I didn't see a single angry drunk.
It was weird cause like there's so many people drunk,
not,
here's one of the things that are draw driver was the coolest fucking guy this
to Jeff and Jeff took us around and Jeff was talking to us about how he could
only live in New Orleans because he had lived outside of New Orleans only for a
little bit.
And he got in trouble with a cop because the cop,
he's talking to the cop about something and he was drinking a beer on the
street.
The cop was asking him where he's coming from and he didn't know that you're not
allowed to drink beer on the street.
You can drink beer anywhere.
You just drink beer on the street.
So while he's talking to the cop,
he said,
he opened up a second beer drinking that and the cop was like,
are you stupid?
Is there something fucking wrong with you?
He goes,
where are you from?
And he goes,
New Orleans.
He's like,
all right,
you can't do that anywhere but there.
Right.
And he was like,
well,
fuck this.
And he moved back to New Orleans is the shit,
man,
that is a,
and we were in Meddory too.
That's,
so we went in,
me and Goldberg and um,
and um,
uh,
delegate and say karate went and had dinner out there and Dunkin and it was
fucking,
what a great town,
man.
People are so fucking friendly.
Thrown this honkytonk slash sports bar on a Friday night.
We're eating cheeseburgers with these people.
You know,
and they're like their local hall and our Saturday night like where do they
hang?
It was bad ass man.
People you met there and Leah's fuck man.
Friendly is fuck like what a great vibe that town as ghost town,
happy vibe.
You see any of the ghost towns like I don't know how much time dude,
I had very little time.
You know there's a problem with,
you know,
I fly in somewhere,
it's like boom.
First thing that I've got to go do the the Wayans and then my comedy show and
then in the morning I get up,
I work out,
I do the UFC.
There's no time really for like too much sightseeing.
Unfortunately it's the greatest job in the world,
but there's no time for a lot of shit.
But we did get to go down in the French quarter.
We walked around Bourbon Street and like this is crazy.
How is this legal?
This is the weirdest thing I've ever seen in my life.
It's beautiful.
First of all,
it's a fucking thing.
It's,
it's really a national treasure.
The fact that a place like this exists and this uptight,
stuck up fucking just scared country we live in now that you could go to a place
and it's strip club,
bar food,
strip club,
bar foods.
This is the recipe.
Yeah,
chickens,
Voodoo all up the street and it's just a swarm like salmon spawning of humanity
with cups in their hands and everybody is fucking blasted.
And we're just wondering through the streets,
checking out the scene and the bars of amazing quote that it don't go the fuck
Outta here.
No one's close and me,
no clothes.
And then she just stays open.
They're just open,
open.
That's tough though.
Like we,
I did a show with Stan hope there a few years ago and uh,
I don't think our show got started until like 1130
or something.
So by the time we got out of there,
it was probably about two.
And we're like,
well,
let's go get a drink at a bar.
And we go to this bar and there's people from the show hanging out.
And I'm like playing pool with a guy and we're getting pretty drunk.
And,
and I was like,
what time is it?
And I look at my fucking phone and it's like seven in the morning and I'm like,
Doug,
it's like seven in the morning.
We've got to like,
we had to leave at like nine 30.
What do you need?
What was it?
Green?
Uh,
I can make some for,
yeah.
Uh,
do you have the crane?
No,
you've worn it for me.
Remember?
Is it in the fridge?
Put it to what?
Did we even finish the story of what you did too?
So we're like,
no,
this isn't the one that most funniest things ever.
Most funniest.
Most fans.
Almost 37 yet.
Look,
I got Internet,
uh,
talk in my head,
man.
I don't talk in full sentences anymore.
It's more gooder
marketer.
But uh,
you pretty much on a,
I love the PR.
You have all this big thing with practical jokes.
Like you did this thing where you print it out.
I think we talked last time where you print it out on top.
A top chef,
top chef.
We'll put it on the billboard.
There's a little thing of him,
you're pouring stew and he put it on.
And then,
uh,
then,
this time you w w the last,
there's a,
in my neighborhood,
there's a vacant circuit city that's been there.
It's been vacant for almost three years.
And I was talking with a friend of mine about how there's no whole foods in our
neighborhood and it,
silver lake's a pretty hipstery like it would be a perfect place for a whole
foods.
And he was like,
yeah,
that would be a good location.
And I was like,
yeah,
it would.
So I made these banners that said,
coming soon,
whole foods,
silver lake and uh,
I'll show,
I have pictures of them.
Um,
and I hung them on the fence around the circuit city.
So everybody thought that,
uh,
that that's silver.
Like with like all these like,
you know,
a hipsters,
we're going to have a whole foods in their,
in their neighborhood.
And it blew the fuck up on Twitter.
It was on like websites,
like Los Angeles weekly and Shit like that.
It,
w it everyone thought whole foods was coming.
It was like a huge deal.
People got really excited and then,
yeah.
And then well,
you know,
you should talk to whole foods and say listen to the demand is here,
right?
Oh,
I'm sure they've talked to them already.
I mean that place has been vacant for so much money to convert it to a
supermarket or something.
I was too expensive.
Have you,
have you always been a practical joke or have you done that your whole life?
Like do you have any like,
like biggest joke he ever did or favorite one that you've ever done?
Uh,
there's,
there's one that you can actually hear.
They played it on another podcast.
Everything I know.
Well,
I mean there's nothing wrong with that though.
Um,
I played the,
I had this card where you can,
it's funny though,
you have to say that though.
You do kind of have to say,
I don't want people,
people like if they only heard the story,
it tells the same fucking,
we're assuming that they're listening to all these different podcasts.
I don't think people have enough time to listen to this podcast.
I think we're deluding ourselves.
Maybe,
I don't know if you're on radio you wouldn't be like,
yeah,
well I said there's a mark and Brian like two months ago.
I might depends.
I don't want to sound like I'm,
all right.
So what happened?
Well,
you can hear it online.
Um,
I called my fried this card,
it's called a spoof card where you can call someone and make it look like it's
coming from any number in the world.
Like I could call you,
make it look like it's coming from the White House.
And uh,
so I called my friend from his wife's number,
his newly ex wife's number and I would make jokes about wanting to bang his wife
all the time and stuff.
So,
so I call him in the middle of the night.
And I think I was telling him that I was,
that I was going to go out on a date with her and I wouldn't really tip my hat
on whether I was joking or not.
And I,
so I call him in the middle of the night from his wife's,
from what looks like his wife's number and I use a voice disguise or did make
kind of sound like a girl.
And uh,
basically I tell him I that it's his wife.
I'm like Yan.
And of course he thinks it's her,
you know,
he just got woken up at four in the morning and I say,
uh,
you know,
I went over to your friend Brennan's tonight.
Fucked up man.
I think he raped me.
And he's like,
wait,
it's a fucking big ass.
His mind.
But then,
but it all ends like it all ends up.
Laughs.
He goes,
cause then he goes,
where are you right now?
And I go,
I'm in the hospital and then there's like a pause and I say,
there's Chis all over me.
And he goes,
fucking Brendan,
I know is you fucking card.
I can't believe you're wasting your card on me.
How does the card work?
Cause it should league.
He just,
you call an 800,
like there's an 800 number that you call legal.
How's this speakers?
Probably in the last four it there's actually,
it's,
it's a lot of people use it.
Lindsay Lohan and was known to always use that for,
for for whatever reasons,
but you can pretty much,
it's like when you use a calling card,
like an old school calling card where you call an 800 number and put in your
code,
but instead of a code you put in whatever phone number you want and then you put
in,
you hit like pound and it calls.
Wow.
Making it look like it comes from that and nonmedical and it'll even say like,
well yeah,
obviously if it's like red ban,
if you put in his number,
his picture comes up on your phone or however ranks when he calls.
How is that legal?
I don't know.
To me,
after a show.
That's crazy.
You could,
you could cause divorces.
Fucking murdered people.
Yeah.
You can do all kinds of crazy shit to somebody who was,
I'd never done anything like,
I've never done any frame on Blake malicious or all the mean people in the world
with some of the like that.
Oh God,
yeah,
they can do some damage.
There's probably some divorced mother fucker googling spoof card right now.
Like,
yeah.
Yeah,
I probably just got them like 10 grand in business.
You should start your own spoof card company.
Yeah,
you should run.
Yeah.
Okay.
Maybe I'll go away from this comedy thing and
yeah,
I'll start a whole new industry.
You need to really get involved in helping people ruin other people's wives
secretly be,
they asked the Madison I'm cloak and dagger shit.
Seems like they shouldn't be able to do that.
I don't understand how that could possibly be legal.
How could you possibly be able to pretend you're someone else and call someone?
I don't think that's legal.
I imagine that that seems like fraud,
you know?
I mean it seems like there would be some sort of a Weirdo.
It's terrorist law to protect you against shit.
I think it falls in the same categories.
Like if you write a letter saying that year you're writing it from the White
House on the returns,
you know,
laying on.
No Dude,
I don't know.
I mean I,
you know,
hopefully I'll get in trouble but I think there's an APP.
No,
I think that it's something that's out there and I don't think it's illegal.
Yeah,
there's a actually an APP.
It's the voice cause you can also do like unknown number.
I don't know.
There's an APP that you can buy that's a voice recorder.
It is called a recorder on the APP store and it's the same kind of idea where
you put in your credit card information and then it filters the call through
this app or something like that and it records it for you so you can record
phone calls using your iPhone.
It's called record
to record phone calls using your eyes.
So yeah.
Record other people's phones.
Yeah,
it uses like same thing where it's like a calling card.
Yeah.
This doesn't seem to go but yeah.
I don't know how this is legal but there's even a button,
this is all recording on the apps on your phone.
Kid might want to rethink your app.
There was one point in time when I had four Fart apps on my phone.
I got a new phone there.
There were a bunch of free,
I know that it's all pretty quick,
but I mean,
whatever
three Fart apps,
what satisfaction that someone have with the mega free fart APP.
One dude put a Joe Rogan I uh,
iPhone application.
Some somebody made one and it's not me,
it's not mine.
But he's selling it.
What to do?
I don't know.
I've looked at it,
but he's selling it.
Well,
there's a lot of,
is he allowed to do that?
I don't think so.
Well,
you're the guy who should probably look into,
yeah,
well I just found out about it.
There's a lot of apps that you have like,
you know,
for celebrities,
they'll have like the Britney spears fan app where it's just like improve your
home address and that's probably what it is.
It's probably something like that where it's like,
I just,
it's like a buck cost.
A dollar.
Some someone's selling it.
You want me to buy it?
Yeah.
Fuck it.
Let's all buy it.
Don't do it.
Let me say it might,
we're advertising something that's done for the wrong place.
Hit the dump onto that.
We don't have a dump.
There's the seven second delay.
No,
we're live dude.
All that creepy
shit you said earlier,
the world know all that shit.
I said seven seconds ago.
Hold on a fucked up shit.
You were thinking,
you know,
um,
it brings me up to that,
uh,
the rose thing again.
This is a funny thing about that style of comedy,
man.
That real mean fucking ridiculous style.
You know,
I'm a big fan of that kind of style of comedy is one of the reasons why I was
kind of upset when that Tracy Morgan thing went down and I was like,
you know,
yeah.
What he said for sure he shouldn't have said that,
but he's out there swinging.
Yeah.
Crazy pitches.
I mean,
he's out there saying the most fucked up shit possible.
It's not that he really means most of this,
right.
This is his act.
His Act is ridiculous and extreme and that's what's so funny about it.
Yeah.
It's like this weird line though where people start judging in as a statement,
you know,
instead of just as something ridiculous and people are just looking for shit to
get upset.
Like people are so like,
we're so fucking ripped off and fucked in this country right now.
It's like,
Oh Tony Bennett said something about nine 11 let's have 9,000 new stories about
that and not about like I and whatever it is might sound like a bit or
something.
But like you hear about all this job creation stuff like talking about we're
going to create jobs,
but just stop outsourcing them.
Is that like,
has anybody said that?
Is that like a popular belief that
well,
I think,
yeah,
a lot of people think that the economy will be much better if we stopped doing
that,
but then I phones would be $7,000
and all of a sudden,
hey,
maybe everybody doesn't have an iPhone.
Thank God there's so many places that have been established.
So many electronics have always been cheap.
Yeah.
Well it's not because we're making them though.
I don't think tank,
I mean,
how many electronics do we make over here?
Barely none.
But like telemarketing could be done here still.
Yeah.
That's my point.
Was it,
I think those people work too hard.
I think if you looked at those,
uh,
what does it Foxconn,
those,
uh,
all those things online about the,
the people who make those iPhones.
Like they would never do that here.
That shit would never get done here,
would never get done.
So yeah,
it's,
you know,
it would,
it just wouldn't happen.
Well,
no,
they can have,
the Asians can keep all the electronic stuff.
They do a good job of that.
We'll just do every,
you know,
like the sitting in a chair trying to sell people shit over the phone.
What was the point about why,
why did we get on the discussion of how much those things cost to make?
I don't know
why.
Attorney to you Brian,
that's when you know it's dark out.
Oh Man.
As we know,
the end is near,
but I'm turning to you.
Did you hear about this fucking computer dealers who figured out the uh,
talking about people?
I'm sorry.
Do you want to move on?
No,
no.
Hold on.
About people being outraged about,
uh,
the met Tracy Morgan.
People are definitely looking,
you're right.
Look,
you need to be out.
Have you heard about the Tony Bennett stuff?
Like when he was on Howard Stern,
he said something about the singer,
the singer.
What'd he say?
He said something about,
uh,
that the,
the terrorists like nine 11 was kind of like,
we've been fucking with people.
It's like,
you know,
it was bound to happen sooner or later.
I don't remember exactly what he said,
but he was like,
well,
you know,
we'd done fucked up shit too.
So,
you know,
I supposed to say that though.
No,
he got a lot of shit,
but I think it's overblown,
which is,
you know,
like the Tracy Morgan thing,
there's just always something with enough buzz words like nine 11 or faggot
where the news can latch onto that and just keep everybody like,
oh,
look over there.
You know,
while they're like fucking stealing all their money.
And
yeah,
it's amazing that the other thing that we accept,
like pretty openly is that in times of war,
you're not supposed to do anything that's gonna possibly damage the soldiers'
morale or a upset the way they look at things like,
you know,
you're not supposed to say things that would,
uh,
you know,
possibly upset them.
You know,
it's kind of,
it's,
which,
you know,
totally makes sense,
but when you stop and think about it,
like what are you asking them to do?
Yeah.
That should I do already in the ward,
you know,
don't you think they're figuring it out by now?
Like,
wait a minute,
this is fucking bullshit going on.
Do you think,
you know,
I mean,
some people can keep it together so people look,
people are meant to do everything.
Then there's people that are meant to do that.
It sounds ridiculous,
but I firmly believe it.
I think there's a broad spectrum of human beings in this world.
Yeah,
no,
it's,
I don't want to bring anybody's more out down.
Why,
why would you,
I think narrowing,
I mean,
do you ever think about joining the military at any point in your life?
No,
not at all.
I've always had a problem with like authorities.
I did too,
but I also thought that I needed discipline,
whatever.
That's when I was 18 I almost joined thought about it.
I wouldn't say almost join,
but I thought about it like as a strong possibility for a couple of days,
which to me at 18 was with my fucking heavy add was a big deal.
I think it would have done me good.
But yeah,
I wouldn't have why always admired people that did it.
I had a few friends that were in the army and I have a few friends that had been
in the marines and they definitely,
it came back like more,
there was something about them,
you know,
they had more confidence,
they had like been through bootcamp and all that shit and they,
there was a passage or coming of age sort of a thing that I hadn't experienced
and I was like,
I think there's something to that.
You know,
I think like boot is good for somebody.
I was always trying to figure out what's the best way to think,
what's the best way to maneuver your way through life?
What is it?
And I was the thing that I was most uncomfortable with,
so I'm like,
I'm fucking Lazy,
man.
I don't like this.